hey what's up my name's Samuel leaves
I'm a property investor and you know
what I just love helping you become more
successful as a property investor so
last week I had a load of questions on
YouTube in the comment box and right now
I'm gonna answer your property
investment questions from last week if
I'm answering these questions and you
have a question right now pop up in your
brain please do comment it below in the
comment box because next week I'm gonna
be answering your questions also don't
forget the smash the like button
subscribe turn the notifications out
armed and let's get started so now
sweeping a guy called mark Bentley you
stay at home you'll hope you're doing
well
just out of curiosity would you be
focusing on HMO or single let's do two
what is happening at this time the
reason I'm asking is because won't it be
harder to find tenants that will move
into a haitch MO rather than a couple or
family to move it to a single let's mark
absolutely not I think that HMOs are
gonna become more and more popular
because as people are losing their jobs
unemployment is high divorce spike is
high people are gonna need to have
affordable accommodation so people that
are currently living in studio
apartments or to bed flats or one
household is becoming two households
they're going to be looking for a fast
affordable convenient accommodation such
as hmm properties so both works but hmm
for sure is a very good strategy in my
opinion over the next few months and
years next
sandor says son/daughter oaks key i hope
i pronounced it right hi stannie on
doing rent to rents in reading awesome
now there's some great business loans
available with nothing to pay for the
next 12 months option this means it will
be easier to raise money for a beat RR
by refurbish refinance I was thinking to
use that money as a bridging loan or buy
the house for cash and refinance it ASAP
the question is so I'm bit confused
because you were talking about rent to
rents and then BRR okay the question is
it's get to the question how quickly can
you refinance or put a mortgage into a
property what are your thoughts thanks
in advance
sandor you can do it straight away with
some lenders however you need to have
been you need to have added value to the
property so companies like Kim Reliance
and precise mortgages you can buy it as
soon as you've added value can we
finance it no
lenders require a six-month period once
you bought the property before you can
refinance but not all and BJ haha this
is funny which lenders will allow you to
refinance your property after a quick
refurb before the six months precise
mortgages and ten reliance there - I
know that will drip because I've done
I've used those guys Li Ambala highest
time you love your content Thank You
Liam on 19 awesome and recently
purchased my first buy-to-let property
after being inspired by your videos dude
that's awesome man
do you know how excited I get when
people come to me and say they're 19 and
they own a by Gillette property because
of the videos respect that's why I do
what I do so I do the videos I look I
tried to look for houses with at least
30 percent return on investment on them
and I have an idea what if I used
investors money to deposit money by
offering them ten percent return on
their money I get that in this chunk of
money gone each month but it's 20
percent for me in otherwise money I
wouldn't fight anyway my investor is on
board and happy to start getting some
decent interest on the money he has
sitting in the bank is this a good
business plan and do you think you could
work for me in the long run to expand my
property portfolio Liam yes absolutely
great idea that's exactly what I did so
the only thing you need to watch is if
you're borrowing money from an investor
the lender is potentially going to ask
you where that money came from so bad
that in mind but it depends on the type
of property deal 100% of the people's
money if you can find deals that I've
given you 20 30 % and you can pay for
them with investors money and just give
them 10% you're getting an infinite
return on investment so you're going to
be very successful me and keep me posted
how you get on Rhys newbs says was you
17 when you viewed your first house also
did you view on your own or did a family
member come with you and help you great
question you know what I was 17 when I
bought my first house I don't know how
old I was when I viewed maybe 16 but
maybe 17 and yeah my first house I think
it was my mom that came with me you know
she's a mobile hairdresser but she's
kind of quite good when it comes to just
stuff she's a very competent person and
all I used to when I was starting out in
property up until the age of about 20
even though I had 21
actually three but I have this complex
but I just thought if I don't bring a
proper adult with me something could go
wrong so yeah I used to always bring a
proper addict with me and my mom has
definitely helped me out even with just
confidence when I started out as a
teenager so respect mom if you're
watching this I know she watched some of
my videos average gamer what do you
think of Gary Vaynerchuk I think he's
awesome
I don't grieve absolutely everything he
says but he's an amazing guy and I have
had the opportunity of meeting with him
and asking him for business advice and
he's been really really helpful Bicknell
says do you think they'll ever become a
day where too many people are trying to
be property investors sure there has to
be a limit as we can't all be landlords
peace and love great question
you know what Bikel firstly because
you're watching my videos you might
think that everyone's trying to be a
property investor but they're actually
not because you're in that world you're
in the world of seeing everyone trying
to make it in property most people
aren't most people are just in a job
saving up to buy their first house to
live in and it will take them 15 years
so the competition is not as big as you
think but also if everyone does stop
buying properties and everyone starts
trying to become a landlord what they'll
do is they'll just change the rules
slightly they'll make it a bit different
like they did when everyone's buying
HMOs probably because of my videos my
training they they started bringing in
article 4 which made it harder and a lot
of people then quit on themselves so
you're always going to have it where if
everyone starts doing it they're going
to make it a bit more difficult and then
the most of the competition I disappear
and the ones that are prepared to be
creative like an aunt rather than turn
back they'll go round the wall or over
it or a new it or through it and people
that prepare to do that will always win
and will always succeed in property and
in any business
good job Sam Hawkins hi Samuel when
sending a letter to a vendor to start
potential lease option agreement if a
response isn't given for a few weeks
what would be your next steps to get
their attention if the letter goes
unnoticed probably wouldn't keep sending
letters to them because that would be
spam but maybe maybe if you've sent a
letter you obviously know their address
maybe it's on Rightmove book if you're
on it just book reviewing on it also
more letters to people
some say says altima apart from
remortgage my ID to let property to
expand my portfolio is there any other
way to raise money I have 15 by 2
at the moment great so you got 15 by
Tourette's respect and you're thinking
should you refinance you know you know
what I imagine some say and I might be
wrong you got 15 by 2 let's see talking
about is there a way to raise finance
apart from refinancing my prediction is
that you're in a well-paid job I'd love
to know if I'm right on this you're paid
what I don't know you from Adam okay
I've never seen you even comment before
my YouTube you're probably paid well and
you've probably been saving you're
probably really frugal you're probably
really good at saving money you probably
live in quite a modest house yourself
but you save and then you invest in
property and you've built up 15
properties you're probably not making
loads of money but you probably making a
little bit of passive income which is
great with your properties my suggestion
would be you need to change your plan
completely I would sell off some of
those houses and start doing a different
strategy lie by refurbish refinance let
me know if I'm right on what I said
about you but yeah you sell some of the
houses and put them into bigger deals
where you can refinance them it's good
saving and buying and doing that it's a
really really slow way so that's my
general advice for you I might be way
off some say I'll hope to hear back from
you let me know Robert Lindsey hi Samuel
is there a way I can get your advice on
something I really don't want to ask you
on the public forum but understand that
you're really busy anyway thanks for the
videos keep up the great work thank you
Robert yeah Robert joined Samuel 3-6-5
gone Samuel 365.com and you'll be able
to get one-on-one mentoring coaching
advice and it's much more bespoke and
specific than you get on YouTube so do
that and someone be able to talk to you
on a one-on-one basis and give you
specific advice and you can join Samuel
fish's five four ninety five pounds per
month and you can you can pay a pound
and get a seven day free trial so
missing one person says of course every
successful person has to have a course I
wonder if Jeff Bezos or Bill Gates or
Elon Musk have the time to read
questions and answer on YouTube or they
are busy managing them for your business
it sounds like missing person we have a
little bit of a skeptic I don't know if
there's a question in there or if that's
a statement but I'll answer it almost
sound listen what you're basically
saying is you're saying that anyone
that's successful in business wouldn't
ever help or give their time to answer
questions just someone that's trying to
emulate what
so I don't agree with that I mean I
don't agree with that and if your logic
was right then that would mean that
there wasn't a single successful person
in the world that ever took the time
what you're doing is you're finding the
one person not the one there's a few but
you're finding one of the few people
like me that actually help and teach
most rich people hide you're right most
rich people come wealthy and they don't
care they just do their thing me I've
become wealthy and now I'm putting
myself out there and I'm sharing what
I've bought what I know so what you're
doing is you're finding the one of the
few people that do that and saying they
must not be being honest they must not
be being authentic because why would
someone do that and if you think like
that then you're probably not going to
become successful yourself but yeah
anyway I hope you find my youtube videos
valuable all the same and enjoy the rest
you day next Edward Michael Roberts
Samuel I'm about to buy my parents house
at cut-rate what's the best way to
refinance and pull my money out to abide
to their property great good stuff
sounds a bit cook though I'm about to
buy my parents house I'm getting a
really cutthroat price don't forget if
you want to refinance it you need to you
need to be able to demonstrate to the
value of that you've increased the value
because if it's worth a hundred and you
buy it for 80 and then you try and
refinance it their value is just gonna
come out and say it's only worth 80 cuz
that's what you bought it for so to
refinance that you need to somehow
increase the value so just bear that in
mind but good job Jack Stevens Samuel
you are changing lives keep doing what
you're doing thank you so much you're
amazing I'm 18 all these young people I
was 18 when I was hustling I'm eighteen
who started my sourcing business six
months ago after doing the deal filing
extravaganza in two crash courses bother
the crash course is a freight good job
since then I've built a list of 172
investors and have sold one deal boom
eighteen came to the crash courses did
some trainings sold a deal respect
what's your question I'm currently a
hurdle and I'm struggling to build a
pipeline of brr deals
due to the competition in the market do
you have any tips for finding rundown
properties apart from like nerve agents
and simply looking around streets aha I
also asked my postman yesterday to let
me know it when he post mail and anyone
on properties Jack Stephen first I want
to say you what awesome secondly is
you made money so you've obviously done
it once you can do it again but my
advice would probably be if you've hit a
hurdle as a deal sorcerer deal sources
tend to have one of two problems either
they've got loads of deals but they
can't sell them because I don't got any
investors all I've got loads of
investors and they can't find the deals
you have got loads of investors you've
sold one deal you got another 172
investors wanting to buy deals but you
haven't got the deals
my advice for me to find another deal
source and it's got the opposite problem
to you and believe me there's a lot of
them and then say hey you've not gotten
the investors but you've got deals give
me a deal I'll sell it up to my investor
and we'll go 50-50 on the profits boom
like that's how you need to stop
thinking but respect jack and I hope to
see you on Samuel 3-6-5 amazing this is
frizzy would you recommend for your
first deal to buy a single let property
yeah sure fair enough if you want to
build your investment portfolio but I'm
going buying the single that property is
not being a property entrepreneur it's
called being a property investor and
it's not a bad place to start by a small
single net property giving a high return
on investment and then build up bigger
and bigger fair fair enough Tyrone
Saxton I like Tyrone Tyrone you're
awesome man we spoke quite a bit just
for feedback can I ask why you don't
ever run any competitions would be fun
to get everyone engaged or have some fun
along the way learning eg prizes such as
free course or free phone call with
yourself free webcam chats just a little
things that don't cost much as well as
the Ling along the way just throwing out
an idea there love it great idea be more
specific
tell me anyone watching this if you've
got any ideas you can always see any
competitions or prizes or things I'm
always open to that so comment your
thoughts and suggestions Thank You
Tyrone and I'll have a think over that
Tony
Scanlan I'll do one more after this and
I'm gonna wrap up hi Samuel I hear all
the flack you've been getting and I just
like to say my wife Sharon and I came on
your crash course back in November 2000
nineteen and we followed your advice yes
we did have a deposit and bought a
semi-detached house for eighty five
thousand pounds spent fifteen on it in
three months we find that step for one
hundred and thirty thousand pounds and
rented it within three hours hundred
pounds a month
dude that's amazing so you boil it for
85 grand you just spent fifty nine it's
100 total then you refinanced it for 130
so you probably pulled out all your
money and that and you ate out within
three hours what
story so to all the people out there
that say you're a scammer etc we did
what you said
and it and still it works by the way we
we did not pay you any money for this
advice so keep up the good work and do
you thank you
Tony and Sharon that's great man listen
I I don't charge generally for my advice
I've I do of course is what you can pay
for I have courses they're expensive I
have courses that are cheap I have free
training and you just got to do whatever
you feel but my um honestly my heart
melts when I had that kind of story so
Tony Scanlon keep going maybe hit me up
on social media and who knows we can
even get you on the channel to share the
story or something that sounds awesome
all right last question Allen Marad hi
Sam you love your content mate I'm
nearly twenty at uni and looking to
start rent to rent business with only
three thousand pounds saved would you
tell us enough to start or do you
recommend waiting a little longer until
I finished uni and have a little bit
more money you've got to do whatever you
want to do if you want to wait and
finish uni and save more money then do
that but if you really itching to gets
tied now get started now three thousand
pound yeah that's enough that's enough
but you've got to be able to get good at
getting money you've got to be able to
get because when you're doing any
business went to rent deal packaging
you're going to need money for stuff for
contracts for solicitors you know some
people still haven't got any money so I
can't do property but if I said to you
I'll give you a free house all you need
to pay for is Baliga fees and the
standard key which is going to be a
three thousand pounds you get the three
thousand pounds for the free house so
you've got to be able to get that kind
of money for little stuff like that but
guys I love doing this I appreciate you
thank you for your questions please do
if you like these videos do hit that
little thumbs up button right there okay
hit the little thumbs up bun or is it
down there I don't know where it is but
find it in smash' and also subscribe and
also turn that little bow on when you're
a subscriber so you don't really miss a
video because I'm going to put in some
very powerful videos coming up very very
soon thank you a priest
peace-out see you next time
[Music]
[Music]